c'est non non je le prends tireur
général des proches de la république
oui s'il vous plaît oui d'abord je veux
vous dire que c'est très content de
passer en deuxième partie de s'entraîner
je suis très touchée par qui bien
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public chéri mon
dieu non appelé monsieur le président où
claude si vous faites comme on dit
claude louis qu'elle est parfois qu'elle
est parfois lourde à porter la robe du
magistrat c'est vrai pourtant surya
dessous
je sais bien que la sérénité la plus
totale devrait être la règle au tribunal
et que plus le crime est grand plus
paisible doit être la décision finale
mais il est immense mesdames et
messieurs les jurés le courroux qui
m'habite sous le bras de quoi le groupe
qui m'habite sous le bras de la justice
sous le bras de la justice cache un
choeur d'hommes avec ses forces et ses
faiblesses et moi mesdames et messieurs
les jurés en tant que procureur de la
république
j'ai la faiblesse de vous le demander
tout aux punis c'est cet homme punissez
l'oeil car c'est un terroriste fourbe un
vandale atrabilaire un anarchiste
exacerbée en un mot un suisse et non
seulement et non seulement il est suisse
mais on l'a vu tout à l'heure il est
gaucher et je vous le demande mesdames
et messieurs les jurés qu'y at il de
plus néfastes qu'un suisse gauche et
sinon un belge dyslexiques monégasque
hypo thyroïdiens ou à l'extrême rigueur
un luxembourgeois polyglotte
ainsi vous voulez détruire le palais de
chaillot monsieur a l'air après cela qui
osera encore prétendre que le péril
helvétique n'est qu'un fantasme et
réactionnaire et petit-bourgeois voulait
détruire le palais de chaillot ce même
palais de chaillot à l'ombre généreuse
ducale mesdames et messieurs les jurés
l'accusée n'a pas craint de s'abriter
par deux fois en 78 et 79 pour y ait
rupture ses calembours je ne vois comme
un patriote poil
s'il est vrai et si ça s'appelle pas
cracher dans la soupe je veux bien
combler détruire toujours détruire
delenda est carthago mulhouse sera
détruite savait déjà césar auguste vingt
siècles plus tard la même fièvre de
destruction hante les hommes on veut
tout détruire
le président somoza les monuments la
peinture et même et même la musique si
l'on croit ce soi-disant musicologue
autrichien qui veut que la statue
viennoise de l'auteur de la symphonie
inachevée soit détruite de schubert
dams et messieurs les jurés vous le
savez le palais de chaillot est l'une
des plus pures merveilles de
l'architecturé de ce siècle avec le
sacré coeur de montmartre et le bâtiment
c de la résidence maurice thorez à livry
gargan
il n'est pas pensable
en pleine année du patrimoine spectacle
que vous laissiez impunis un guérillero
palestino helvétique prête à tout pour
casser nos belles pierres oui mesdames
et messieurs les jurés
oui mon p'tit claude neuf oui monsieur
paul dans le nommer a l'air de son vrai
nom aura l'air tout est nommé à l'air
doit payer
c'est un être profondément méchant il ne
s'en cache pas
pour faire rire l'homme doit être cruel
at il déclaré récemment alors par
exemple si le président de la république
s'est cassé la gueule à la tribune
savent offrir chabat le sol pas
d'attaqué en plus de ça monsieur allaire
n'a pas craint d'affirmer dans un autre
journal
et là je vous cite encore j'aime tout ce
qui est à vapeur on l'a vu tout à
l'heure ils donnent tout ce qui est à
vapeur at on idée d'être aussi
farouchement hétérosexuels et pour en
finir avec vos déclarations ignoble à la
presse monsieur a l'air je rappellerai
au jury que vous avez déclaré le 27
octobre 1977 au journal informe oui mon
humour est ambiguë le lendemain le
journal se casser la gueule c'est pas
ambiguë avant de vous demander de sévir
mesdames et messieurs les jurés
j'ai longuement réfléchi prenons mettait
à demain si vous le voulez bien bien
monsieur a l'air vous allez payer je
demande au jury de condamner l'accusé a
ravalé le palais de chaillot avec une
brosse à dents en poils de banquiers
suisses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
etonnant non